-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
Also, it's Thursday.
Let's get to the news.
[ Laughter ]
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
arrived in Japan today
for the 2020 Tokyo Olympics,
so, now, they just need
about 1,000 more doctors.
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
yesterday rejected
two of Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy's picks
to sit on the select committee
investigating the January attack
on the Capitol,
specifically, the podium thief
and the Viking guy.
[ Laughter ]
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
has announced that Republicans
will run their own investigation
into the January incident,
so get ready to find out
Hillary did it!
Lawmakers in Las Vegas
have voted against a measure
that would impose a mask mandate
on tourists visiting The Strip
because, hey,
you're there to gamble.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
women spend more money
on home decor, health,
and clothes than men
because, for men,
that's all one expense.
"Hey, I cut my hand.
Can I use that T-shirt
you're using as a curtain
to bandage it up?"
[ Laughter ]
The world's fastest bullet train
was recently unveiled in China
which can travel
at over 370 miles per hour
That means that,
in less than a day,
you could be on the other side
of the country,
buying new underwear.
[ Laughter ]
Amazon has begun offering a more
masculine-sounding voice optio
for its virtual assistant Alexa.
It's the only virtual assistan
that will talk over you.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, today is
National Hammock Day.
I don't like to make plans
on Hammock Day
because they're really har
to get out of.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh! Look who's venturing
into the realm of Mike Scollins.
Bryan Donaldson
has made his move.
The Donaldson Gambit!
[ Laughter ]
And that's was a monologue